[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
a moment of extreme danger for the world
boris johnson said yesterday
he will not stop at ukraine the foreign
secretary writes this morning
the ukrainian leader warns the west
against appeasement
but it's all western hype says the
kremlin
well so far it's largely been a war of
words each side accusing the other of
bad faith
whoever said that truth is the first
casualty of war had a point
what we do know this weekend is that
bullets are starting to fly though we
can't be sure who fired first
on friday mr putin supervised the
testing of russia's nuclear weapons just
a routine exercise his officials claim
not intimidating at all
but mr biden says that invasion is just
a matter of when not if
well we'll do our best to sift the fact
from the fiction for you in the next 60
minutes
the minister for europe james cleverley
will be here to tell us more about the
government's position on ukraine as well
as matters closer to home
the shadow health secretary where
streeting will give us labor's take
russia's deputy ambassador to the united
nations dmitry polyansky will give us
moscow's
perspective on the ukraine crisis
the united states former ambassador to
nato k bailey hutchinson will give us
the view from washington
simon fraser the former head of the
foreign office he'll tell us how much
influence the uk really has over what
happens in ukraine
and with elections at stormont looming
we sat down with one of the front
runners to become first minister shin
faints michelle o'neal to find out more
about her vision for northern ireland
but first let's talk to the europe
minister james cleverley
good morning mr cleverley
trevor good morning
the munich security conference continues
today um are we any closer to a
diplomatic solution to this crisis or is
the threat of invasion as great as ever
well the simple truth is that russia
still has
a huge an unprecedented number of troops
on the ukrainian border whilst those
troops are there and whilst they have uh
combat enablers that means the logistics
the medical support that kind of stuff
that you only really need for a full
military conflict it's it's not
explained away just by an exercise
whilst those things are there the threat
is real and the attack could come at any
time now the prime minister made it
clear we are still going to pursue
diplomatic roots we still want to avoid
a conflict rather than c1 roll out and
so that's what we're going to continue
doing
and we're going to try and make sure
that vladimir putin understands that an
invasion would come at a huge cost both
human costs and financial cost to him
and the people around him
that may be your hope mr cleverley but
the president of the united states on
friday told washington
reported in washington that
as of this moment i'm convinced he's
made the decision we have reason to
believe that
war is coming
well
unfortunately none of the things that we
had hoped to see none of the
de-escalation when i was in the united
nations in new york
at the tail end of last week both myself
and all the other people speaking called
for de-escalation we haven't seen that
we've seen increased troop numbers we've
seen now more aggressive more
belligerent activity by the russia by
russia we're not seeing the things that
we had hoped to see so unfortunately at
the moment
a
an attack an invasion seems far more
likely than unlikely but we will
continue to work to try and avert that
far more likely than unlikely you put
the chances of invasion higher than 50
50.
well at the moment as i say everything
that we see indicates that an invasion
is very very highly likely and very very
imminent now we will continue working
every day that we can prevent this
conflict is a good day at work so we
will continue working to try and avert
conflict to
let russia know to let vladimir putin
know
that there will be significant
consequences from the international
community including from the uk through
sanctions
i'm just trying to get clarity really on
on where the government's mind is at the
foreign secretary your boss liz trust
says that mr putin will not stop at the
ukraine and he at ukraine and he will
then target the baltic states now if the
kremlin really does have these
expansionist plans that you believe that
then why not level with us and say that
we had better prepare for war
because
in the end if that's what he's going to
do
there's not going to be any way of
stopping him other than militarily
well we
are trying very hard to prevent conflict
from happening what we have seen is we
have seen incursions from russia uh into
uh crimea into the donbass uh into um
georgia into other parts of central
europe so when the foreign secretary
says that you know this is not gonna be
it all the history has shown us that
there is continued aggression coming out
from the kremlin we're trying to prevent
that we're trying to stop that but we
also recognize that the eastern nato
allies are also um
watching what's going on and we're
seeking to give them reassurance of our
strength of unity through nato so we're
reinforcing our eastern nato allies now
ukraine is not part of nato and so
that's a very different prospect and
what we're looking to do is deter
through
uh diplomatic means and the threat of
sanctions um but the simple truth is
russia has shown itself to be a very
aggressive neighbor and we need them to
stop
but it looks here like that there is
the potential let's put it that way for
a spiral in his speech at the munich uh
security conference yesterday the prime
minister listed the troops that he's
sending to estonia and poland
he talked about an increased aerial
presence in southeastern europe and the
deployment of warships in the
mediterranean and the black sea
look
is there a danger that we're making
conflict more likely by such an obvious
buildup of forces
well the thing that's made made conflict
more likely trevor is the nearly 150 000
russian troops amassed on ukrainian uh
borders on the north the east and the
southern borders of ukraine and
unprecedented a larger accumulation of
military power
since at any time since the second world
war that is what uh the reality is we
are reacting nato is a purely defensive
alliance it has never expanded by force
it has never expanded by coercion the
countries that join nato join nato
because they uh they want to exist under
the umbrella of shared protection that
nato provides the aggressor here is
russia and what we are trying to do is
to say that we will stand by our friends
and allies in nato and we will support
uh democracy
sovereignty uh the rule of law when it
comes to ukraine
i suppose the the question here and you
talked to a moment ago about the lessons
of history
and that the lesson sometimes that we've
learned
is that events can take on a momentum of
their own and build up on both sides
could take us potentially to a place
where
nobody feels that they can back down and
whilst you and the diplomats are using
the language
of resolution and reconciliation and
finding solutions
the facts on the ground point to further
conflict uh and i suppose what i'm
really asking is to what extent are we
in danger of playing a part
uh as it were in
creating
uh that spiral towards uh conflict
well trevor let's let's let's think
about what the credible alternative
would be do we think it is realistic
that we watch the largest build-up of
military troops since the second world
war on the border of the sovereign
nation a border which has already been
invaded by russia in uh 2014 do we sit
back
pretend that's not happening
and uh and send the signal both to
russia and more broadly that we do not
take seriously threats and intimidation
towards uh democratic states that's not
a credible
position we are working
round the clock
to try and prevent this conflict but
we're all making it clear that we
support our nato allies
and that's why those troop deployments
have happened
but also
we support we support the sovereignty
and democracy and the rule of law when
it comes to ukraine the
years from russia
let's cut through this
we have these forces we are
pointing out that they are there
if there is an invasion
how will we or the nato allies use those
forces what are our military options
well
we've got to understand there are
two things kind of wrapped up in that
question
uh nato
uh will support itself or support the
member states of nato ukraine is not a
nato member state but we have given
equipment support and training support
to ukraine through operation indeed but
he's not he's not invading hungary he's
not in va invading poland
he's potentially invading ukraine so how
could we use our forces in the case of
an invasion of ukraine
so that's the point i'm saying the the
forces that we're sending to our nato
allies of the nato defense for ukraine
we have given the support of defensive
military equipment and training we are
not envisaging sending
british or nato forces to ukraine we are
we have helped them defend themselves
through that training and equipment
support
and um we have laid a
regime a sanctions regime which means
that we could apply meaningful and
painful sanctions to the money people
around vladimir putin if he were to take
part in or if he were to initiate an
invasion but it's really important that
we see the distinction between those two
things all right well let's let's talk
about the money um here's what the prime
minister had to say yesterday on this
question of financial sanctions
he said i don't think that it's fair to
say the uk hasn't done a huge amount on
dirty money whether it's from russia or
anywhere else actually globally we've
been out in the lead in tackling global
corruption in tracing the sources of the
ill-gotten gains we've imposed some very
tough sanctions if you recall after the
russian annexation of crimea of
sevastopol in 2014. now one of the
main instruments that he's talking about
then tackling global corruption is the
unexplained wealth order which requires
individuals to reveal the source
of their vast sums of money
can you tell me
how many of those have been issued since
boris johnson
uh became prime minister
i don't i don't have that figure i don't
know i haven't i i do i do
uh the answer is zero
well
you
you suggested in your question that is
the main way i don't necessarily agree
that is that
i'm not suggesting it i'm telling you
that's what your colleague said to me
when they were sitting here liz truss um
and uh another of your cabinet
colleagues said that to me in the last
uh two weeks that is the thing that they
pinned uh their hopes on
i
would be surprised if that's quite the
language they use but nevertheless well
i can show you the clip if you really
want to get into that but they said it
to me so the point the point is that we
have a range we have a range
of uh ways of dealing with illicit
finance we are indeed one of the uh
leaders in terms of tackling uh elicit
finance we take it very very seriously
we're working
with
other financial jurisdictions around the
world to make sure that the
the whole global approach because it
does need to be a global approach to
illicit finance is coordinated and
robust
the point is
that the prime minister has made it
absolutely clear
through the sanctions regime the
expanded sanctions regime the toughest
sanction regime that we have ever had
with regards to russian money is now in
place and were there to be an invasion
it would be used and those individuals
those money people around vladimir putin
would absolutely feel it we're making it
very very clear that we will respond and
we will respond robustly if there is
invasion into ukraine
if i may say so the prime minister's
made it very clear in words but i think
mr putin and others look at actions uh
these uh orders have actually been used
five times since they came in to
being and none of them has been used
against
russians and in addition to that what we
also know is that
the international financial system
assisted by russian legislation it makes
it almost
impossible to trace uh the source of
this dirty money a lot of the people
that have been named
bring their money into london via other
jurisdictions cayman islands cyprus and
so on
how can vladimir putin really take this
seriously when
he can see by our actions we just don't
use the powers that we've already got
never mind any powers that you might
want to introduce now
well
one of the things you have to understand
trevor is the difference between an
unexplained wealth order and
sanctions the sanctions are a different
vehicle we have used sanctions as the
prime minister has said in the in the
quote that you have given we have used
sanctions in response to the sales
reporting and attack uh by russian
intelligence agents on british soil we
coordinated the largest uh
expulsion or yeah we facilitated the
largest coordinated expulsion of
undocumented russian agents in response
to that so we have already applied
sanctions we are willing to apply more
so the hypothesis you're putting forward
that somehow we haven't taken action is
just not borne out by the facts we have
and we will in the event of a another
incursion into ukraine by russia
all right let's talk uh if we may for a
moment about covid prime minister is
apparently going to announce the lifting
of all coveted restrictions tomorrow
uh is it all over
well the thing with the disease is never
completely over but what we have seen
is because of the the research to be
doing the genomic research that we do
here in the uk world-class uh research
because of the uh production
distribution uh and uh
and
the the vaccination program the booster
program we have broken the link between
infections and hospitalizations we are
we are seeing the uh we're seeing that
the disease now it's it's changed into a
much much milder form we will of course
remain vigilant that's incredibly
important but we are in a position now
where we can follow the data follow
the the science evidence that we have
seen and move back towards a normal
state where we we recognize we have to
live with disease we
we've always had to live with diseases
we're going to have to live with this
disease but we do also want to get back
to normal
can we just clear one thing up for a
local authority leaders who've noted
that um the press release from the
government on this says that local
authorities will still be expected to
manage outbreaks with pre-existing
health powers
is that a signal to them that if there
is a further
uh
virus outbreak a new variation so on
that there won't be
any more money available
now for um trevor what this is is this
is a recognition that we've had
pre-existing contingency planning
for disease outbreaks at local
government level when i was uh when i
was working with um the prime minister
when he was mayor of london i chair the
london resilience forum and we had
contingency plans
for how local authorities would deal
with disease outbreaks in their area
what we're saying now is that is that
the the era where we're having a
additional
differentiated
responses to covid is going to be over
and we're going to move back to the
pre-existing regime where local
authorities have plans and these plans
are are well circulated well tested uh
and and um
pre-existing and those are what we're
expecting local uh local authorities to
rely on from this point well from from
when the announcement's made moving
forward
and they will but they will have to uh
carry out those plans based on their
existing resources there won't be a new
bunch of money from the treasury
well as as this as we've seen with
omnicron uh clovid is now
much more similar to other less
um
also
less well-known diseases which are in
circulation which local authorities have
plans to deal with have plans to deal
with and what we're saying is that is
the regime
that we're going to move towards
all right um you just pointed out uh
that you've been
at the uh prime minister's right hand in
various ways for many years from his
days in city hall so you know him
pretty well um let me ask you a couple
of questions about uh the questionnaire
which he's now returned to the
metropolitan police uh outlining his
responses to their questions about
parties and downing street and all of
that
if the prime minister were issued with a
fixed penalty notice will that be made
public
so i haven't discussed this directly
with him i understand he's made a
statement about
putting
information in the public domain you
have to rely on the on the words that he
has already given to that when i uh get
the chance to speak to him i have to say
i speak to him about the issues we've
been speaking about previously about uh
the situation with ukraine the situation
with russia and the other elements of my
foreign office portfolio so you'll have
to forgive me i've not discussed that
with him um we've been discussing uh
things like uh iran and ukraine all
right
all right
well let me ask you uh uh maybe a
simpler more direct question about uh
if you like
his mind and the way it works which
frankly you will know better than
most
if he were to get
a fixed penalty notice and therefore by
implication in some way has broken the
law will he resign
i think what the prime minister and this
is reinforced by the uh the
conversations that i've had with him and
the announcements that he's made
publicly i think the prime minister is
focused on continuing with the work that
we've done beating yeah but yeah but he
would he would be pretty focused
he'd be pretty focused on the penalty
notice he gets will he resign if he gets
one
well i don't think uh i don't think what
the country needs at the moment is a
vacuum at the center of government when
we are dealing with our recovery from
covid the accumulation of russian troops
on the ukrainian border
making sure that the uh the health
service is able to deal with the sad but
unfortunately the unfortunate but but
nevertheless uh um
obvious backlog that has been created by
kobe that's what the country needs
that's what um that's what i believe the
prime minister should uh should be doing
well i'm taking that as a gnome minister
thank james cleverley thank you very
much indeed
you're taking in trouble that's exactly
how you should be taking it
okay
let's get labor's view with the shadow
health secretary wes streeting
um mistreating we're going to come to
covid which is your own territory in a
moment but can we start with ukraine is
labour still foursquare behind the prime
minister
yes look we need to see robust and
united
international action to prevent the
situation in ukraine from escalating
there is a there are two sides to this
there is the side of ukraine which is an
argument for freedom democracy
self-determination and on the other side
you have russian aggression so we stand
four square united here and within the
uk and squarely alongside our nato
allies that's exactly where we should be
but of course alongside robust action
abroad we also need to see robust action
at home from the government particularly
tackling uh illicit dirty russian money
which is flowing through the city of
london and unfortunately it seems also
flowing through the coffers of the
conservative party so i think there's a
lot more to be done to clean up our act
here at home to stop the city of london
being the destination of choice for
russian kleptocrats and money laundering
well let's take those two things in turn
let's start with uh abroad
are you at all worried that there's a
danger that
this thing could escalate inadvertently
into a situation where uh there's a
conflict that as the prime minister has
said in the last 24 hours
could engulf europe
well let's hope not and there is still
time for president putin to do the right
thing
we hope the situation will not escalate
further in fact all of the efforts right
across the nato alliance are on
de-escalation as as it should be but
president putin should also be in no
doubt about the resolve of the uk on a
cross-party basis the resolve of nato
working across the multilateral alliance
to take robust action if president putin
makes the choice to escalate the
situation further
so you support you support the
deployments
of which the prime minister spoke
yesterday in the black sea and in uh
neighboring states to ukraine
we support the government of ukraine we
support the ukraine armed forces that's
the right thing to do and it's also
important to send a message to our
allies right across the region that the
uk is with them this is you know the
nato alliance has been the cornerstone
of western defense and democracy uh
since it was created in 1949 and and the
then labour government led by clement
atley played a critical um role of which
we're enormously proud of in the labour
party and it's important that today
president putin understands that
alliance remains strong it is by its
nature a defensive alliance we want to
see de-escalation of the situation but
the uk stands ready to support the
government of ukraine as we're already
doing and also to support nato allies
right across the region
all right well let's take the other arm
of your policy which is domestic
sanctions and
the pursuit of dirty money as you called
it
um i think you heard what uh mr
cleverley had to say do you accept his
assurances that the government really
means it this time
uh not really because we've had the
cross-party russia report of the
intelligence and security committee
of the house of commons which set out a
whole range of
recommendations to help clean up our act
here at home and to protect our
democracy from russian interference that
report has not been implemented we have
an elections bill going through
parliament right now which ironically
would make it easier for foreign money
to pollute our politics we've got to put
a stop to that so
when boris johnson threatens tough
sanctions against president putin he
knows he'll have our support in
implementing those sanctions but our
message to the prime minister is that he
and his government should have acted far
sooner to clean up money laundering in
the city of london and also to clean up
the conservative party's app when it
comes to the donations it receives from
individuals linked to the russian
government you um a couple of weeks ago
your party put out a list of named
individuals who you
said had given money to the conservative
party and uh you implied that they would
influence policy
uh in a way
advantageous to mr putin
what evidence do you have that any of
these people
has had any influence on what the
government
does
well take a look at the sunday papers
today which i don't know what everybody
is there you put this out two weeks ago
that's an important thing they have any
influence whatsoever
so we know that donors have an enormous
degree of influence over the policies
and priorities of the conservative
government uh that's been known for some
time and has been laid bare in today's
sunday newspapers
you've got people
like the chanukins a former deputy
finance minister
in president putin's regime his wife has
given more than two million pounds to
the conservative party so i think there
are questions for them to answer on this
and it's
is making the right decisions for the
right reasons with respect mr streeting
if somebody said that about a labour
party donor you would be using the word
smear
let me ask you again
take miss sir mr chnukin
what evidence do you have that mr
newkin has had any influence on what the
government has done what is it that he
has asked for that you can say the
government has done
well today we learn that his wife who's
given significant amounts of money to
the conservative party has been
attending meetings with the prime
minister's former chief of staff lord
lister
on this advisory board for the
conservative party where donors have a
direct route into number 10 to influence
government policy so i think the
government have got serious questions to
ask about that uh of course we're
particularly concerned in the context of
our discussion this morning about those
individuals with links to president
putin's regime but this applies more
broadly in terms of our politics which
is that it can't just be big money
donors that call the shots in our
democracy we need to make sure the
government is acting in the interests of
all of the people of the united kingdom
not just those with big wallets funding
the conservative party
uh we are if i may say so talking about
newspaper reporting and i i want to be
clear with everybody who is watching
that as far as we know there is no
evidence to uh
support
the suggestion that uh that that uh
there has been specific influence but
let's move on if i may quickly to your
area of responsibility and covert
if mr johnson lifts all the covered
restrictions will you support that
well i'm particularly concerned about
the end of free testing i mean it's a
bit like being 2-1 up with 10 minutes
left of play and subbing your best
defender we are not out of the woods yet
on covid and it's important that when
the government publishes its plan for
living with clover tomorrow that it is a
robust plan that enables everyone to
live well with covid we published our
plan back in january and i came on your
program to talk about it then there are
a number of sensible steps that can and
should be taken to ensure that we can
live well with covid without impacting
on people's lives livelihoods and
liberties access to free testing right
now given the prevalence of the virus
given the fact we're still asking people
to isolate at home if they have the
virus if they're infectious it's a
really critical tool acting on sick pay
would also make an enormous difference
and and frankly it's inexplicable the
government haven't acted already on this
and just this week we saw businesses and
unions the federation of small
businesses the trade union congress
aligned on this so and look i tend to
find i've got a church with near the
choir singing next to me when you've got
business and unions singing from the
same hint sheet it's usually a good idea
to dance to their tune because they're
you know they're they're and they're
right on this we've got to act on sick
pay so there are a number of things the
government can do to make sure that we
can live well with the virus and i don't
think boris johnson and his government
should be complacent about the fact that
whether it's a million or so clinically
extremely vulnerable people who are
really worried lots of pensioners and
older people who are still worried about
the virus making sure we've got sensible
measures in place like free testing
gives people the confidence to go about
their daily lives safe in the knowledge
that they're protected from the risk of
the virus okay mr street we're running
out of time but i i'd be remiss if i
didn't ask you a very quick question if
and a quick answer if i may uh about the
report this week that labor is planning
not
to put resources into seats which
are targeted by the liberal democrats um
short question really is
confronted with the possibility of
another tory government or an
understanding with the liberal democrats
wouldn't you personally choose an
understanding with liberal democrats
well i can tell you there have been no
talks formal or informal with the
liberal democrats it is just a simple
matter of fact that there are a number
of seats
at the next election where the liberal
democrats are in contention the labour
party isn't far more seats where the
labour party is in contention and the
liberal democrats are not and as as
political parties we will obviously
target our resources where we can to
make sure we win as many seats as
possible get rid of this rotten tory
government and have a credible serious
prime minister in kierstama focused on
the real issues facing the country
whether that's the rising cost of living
or the or the need to make sure we
rebuild out of the pandemic and that's
what labour's focused on
okay i'm taking that as a yes good mor
thank you very much mr streeting
okay now
let's get more on the ukraine crisis the
million dollar question remains what is
vladimir putin's game plan an estimated
150 000 russian troops are masked on the
border but will he order them to attack
dmitry polyansky is russia's deputy
permanent representative to the united
nations
mr ambassador a couple of days ago you
said that
claims of an imminent invasion of
ukraine by the russians
are nonsense baseless and
paranoid do you still think that
absolutely
i think recently we have determined the
exact date of of our invasion together
with my colleague diplomats here in new
york is the 30th of february i think you
can mark this date in your calendar if
you find it of course if that is the
case what is the point of 150 000 troops
on the ukrainian border what are they
doing there first of all who counted
them
where do you take this figure 150 000. i
remember it was 100 000 then it was 120
000. now it is 150 000. some people say
190 000. so i admit inflation is very
high here in new york we see it on the
prices but in the number of soldiers i
think it's inflation demonstrated by
satellite pictures which we have seen
and unless unless the russia is now
putting in
cardboard tanks uh there are
troops there
well we don't trust the u.s and british
intelligence they let it let us down the
whole world on many occasions enough to
remember
weapons of mass destruction in iraq but
in any case you asked about what are the
troops doing there well they are on our
territory they are not placed on the
border immediately they are placed in
the uh in the uh their places where they
usually are on the border would you be
as relaxed if they were the other way
around and ukraine had moved let's say
that the ukrainians had 50 000 troops
and they moved to within a kilometer of
the russian border would you be as
relaxed about it as as you are we are
not relaxed and you are very close to
the truth because ukrainians have 120
000 on the line of contact with donbass
and they started shelling donbass
yesterday that's why of course we are
not relaxed are you now accusing the
ukrainians of aggression i am not
accusing them of aggression i am
accusing them of shelling peaceful
population in donbas and this is quite
obvious given it's not about from the
satellites but it's from the people
there from the eyewitnesses i think that
uh the osce monitoring mission also made
this in the in today's report as far as
as far as i was
informed so this is a fact of life
whether it's aggression or not difficult
to say but when you have 120 000 troops
in full uh in full uh capacity to strike
at the border
the line of contact actually i think you
have to be preoccupied and you have to
think about aggression it's not russian
troops on russia
all right well look we can trade numbers
but one thing that we are absolutely
certain about is that mr putin has uh
said
that he is going to conduct
nuclear drills and he will oversee them
himself isn't that a rather dangerous
escalation of the situation which you
yourself have just been describing as a
tense one i don't think that everybody
should tell us when we should or
shouldn't conduct drills our drills
happened before we announced a number of
drills beforehand by the way these were
these in belarussia
that also went in the center of
attention were announced months ago and
they are now being presented as a kind
of russian alleged escalation this is
not true i'm not i'm not i don't think
that our drills on our territory should
should worry anyone yes but mr putin is
a smart man he must know that in the
context
uh announcing a nuclear drill nuclear
drill
isn't going to reduce the tensions is it
well if you have nuclear weapons of
course you need to keep keep keep it in
good shape so drills are necessary from
time to time i'm not responsible for
this
question of course i can't speak for my
president in this regard i'm sure that
he had good reasons to announce these
drills
there are a lot of issues i think that
the world should be preoccupied more
than our drills on our territory uh so
i'm really very much
not understanding uh what is the what is
the point of being super preoccupied
there some western commentators are
saying that
what is actually happening is that mr
putin didn't anticipate
the western resolve that he would have
to face in the form of nato and european
unity
given the buildup of troops on the
ukraine border has he misjudged the
situation i would say that uh there are
a lot of things for the world to be
preoccupied right now
and uh you shouldn't uh judge it in
terms of chess board in terms in terms
of geopolitical struggle i think we made
quite clear that we have absolutely
legitimate concerns uh about our
security uh which is being affected by
nato placement of infrastructure and
troops near our border and we we have
the right to be concerned so we made
concrete proposals these proposals are
long overdue it's not the first time
that we voice our preoccupations i think
we did it for tens of years already we
base our preoccupations on the
provisions of basic osce
documents of russian nato act and also
on some promises which
western leaders have given us so this is
quite logical and i think what people
what peace loving people in europe
should be preoccupied is really to stop
the militaristic uh
tune that is now in the heads of many
many western politicians unfortunately
and to to get to negotiating table and
to see what we can together do in terms
of security for guaranteeing
russia's absolutely legitimate concerns
well can i just put lastly another
reading of this situation to you which
is this
that
mr putin
is rather enjoying this
that he has western leaders coming to
his table
he has a western media talking about him
as we are doing now and that actually
the eyes of the world are on this
situation and indeed the eyes of the
russian people are on this situation
diverting them from russia's own
economic problems i think that enjoying
is not the right word that you can use
in these circumstances when we see
absolutely lack of responsibility from
on behalf of western leaders right now
and a lot of uh scare monitoring and war
mongering so i don't know anybody who is
enjoying this situation in russia
and what you said about russia's
economic difficulties well every country
has economic difficulties i assume uk
also has some
after the brexit as well there is a
trend
that uh people say that the problems are
narrowed down to ukraine and to solving
this artificial crisis around ukraine
with alleged russian uh in russian plans
to attack but i want to tell you that
the picture is much bigger and ukraine
is only one piece of this puzzle and
that was exactly we assume i assume
personally that it was exactly the
tactics of our western partners to to
start all this hype when we uh inform
them about our proposal and when we send
to them draft treaties with u.s and nato
about european security this is a very
strange coincidence isn't it ambassador
thank you very much indeed for your time
this morning thank you
joe biden said this weekend that he
believes russian military action in
ukraine is imminent
but what can washington do to stop it
k bailey hutchison is a former
ambassador to nato
ambassador thank you for
joining us
you've watched mr putin for some time
what do you think he actually wants out
of this crisis
i think president putin is testing the
western alliance certainly nato he's
testing america
uh he wants to see how far he can go
he has the history of
going into georgia taking two provinces
there
and having relatively little blowback
um same thing with crimea in 2014
and i think he sees a potential to
disrupt the alliance to cause
dissension in the alliance and i think
he is testing to see how far he can go
i spoke to um
dmitry polanski who is the deputy
ambassador to the united nations for
russia and i i put it to him
that actually
mr putin
aside from what of his ultimate
objections might be
maybe rather enjoying the situation
because he's destabilizing
the west he has people talking about him
he has western leaders coming to his
table
do you think
in some senses it will pay him
to play this long and play it out for as
long as he can
i think that is
clearly something that he relishes that
he would be getting this much attention
uh and he is trying to cause dissension
in nato
i believe that we can all say that he's
actually done the opposite he has made
nato much more united much more unified
uh in speaking uh to to russia and
seeing
what they do
do you think that there is any realistic
military response open to nato
were there to be a russian incursion
well i think there will be
uh cyber uh you know this is my
uh prognostication that it would be
yes in cyber that there could be
military uh in the cyber arena
because uh putin has clearly shown that
he will use cyber attacks and he will
use disruptive
uh cyber uh messaging
but also
shut down and and he's used malware as
well as ransomware
um he's been connected to those kinds of
attacks in our country as well as others
so i think on the cyber front yes that
there could be uh attacks back we have
the capability to attack back and i
think that is one of the tools in the
toolbox so you think a military conflict
uh on the ground is unlikely that's my
view but i cannot say that i would bet
the ranch on it as we would say in texas
um i don't know if he would really um
be able to convince his people
that
it would be worth
killing russian soldiers the ukraines
would lose but also russia would as well
and i don't think he would want that so
i would i would err on the side that he
wouldn't do that but i do think he will
do a lot of damage in other ways
if there is going to be a way out of
this uh
in the diplomatic
sphere
would one way of starting this be simply
for nato to rule out the possibility of
ukraine joining nato
i do not think that is an option
because
everyone
is is i think unified in saying
that
it would be such a sign of weakness
for nato to pledge to russia
that we wouldn't take in any other
country that seeks
membership in our nato alliance i don't
think we would ever do it and
i think it would be the wrong signal
what we need to do is show strength
i think that's what putin understands is
strength and unity and uh
there's no way that we would sit back
and let putin then have a veto over a
country that qualifies the last point um
do you think the united states could
help
to as it were stiffen europe's spine by
saying for example it will guarantee gas
supplies to europe
in the event that the russians decided
to put the squeeze on energy supplies
from siberia to the western europe we
definitely need to do that that is
something that has been
talked about but i think now is the time
for action uh we have
fun abundance
energy resources in america and natural
gas that we could export but we have to
be able to get the receiving facilities
in our european countries and there have
been
many obstacles to those receiving
facilities being built but we can
provide affordable natural gas which is
clean energy
to our european allies and that's what
we ought to be promoting much more now
uh that we have seen that russia really
will use gas as a leverage and that is
the next step that i think uh will come
up in congress and i hope that the
administration will work with congress
to
uh start promoting natural gas exports
ambassador thank you so much for your
time trevor thank you it's been great to
visit with you
speaking at the security conference in
munich yesterday boris johnson said an
invasion of ukraine would send a shock
around the world
he said that severe economic sanctions
will be imposed if one does take place
but is that going to be enough to deter
vladimir putin joining me now is simon
fraser who's a former head of the
foreign office
good morning simon um good morning
you're a seasoned diplomat you've seen a
lot of this um are we really facing the
biggest land war in europe as described
by the prime minister
well of course it's always difficult to
disentangle the disinformation from the
from the facts but it does seem that
actually contrary to what a lot of the
experts have been predicting over recent
weeks
we may well be moving in that direction
and we do have to take very seriously
the warnings that are being issued by
president biden and the prime minister
and others now i think so the situation
does look pretty uh alarming at the
moment
the um the conference is still going on
but the russians aren't there um
can there be a diplomatic solution if
they just aren't even turning up
well it's true that they're not there
and i think that what that tells us is
that
president putin is not at the moment
really interested in negotiation and a
negotiated solution uh he's made demands
which he knew nato and the americans
could not accept he's kept the door open
a bit through uh the discussions of the
activity of his foreign minister lavrov
but it doesn't seem to me at the moment
that there is a very active disposition
to negotiate on the russian side and i
mean there are ways in which
negotiations could be taken forward
if both sides wanted to do it but one
thing's really important to say we can't
negotiate with russia if russia has
broken international law has infringed
the sovereignty of ukraine
and has invaded so the window for
diplomacy at the moment the current
window for diplomacy does look as if it
may be closing
taking all of that together do you agree
with the europe minister james cleverley
when he says as he did earlier in this
program
that uh an invasion is more likely today
than not likely
i just don't know the answer to that i
mean if you
you know if you look at this rationally
from our perspective you would say that
the risks for putin of doing that are
immense
and he's going to incur huge economic
political military and human cost
if he does that
but what we have to be always aware of
is that other people don't always see
the world through the same perspective
as us and we have to understand the
different motivators that are driving uh
president putin to this action uh even
if we don't agree with them we have to
try and understand them uh i can't tell
you exactly what's going on in his head
and what he's gonna do i think we do
have to take the risk seriously
well what's going on his head as you say
uh is a bit of a a mystery but um the
foreign secretary this morning appears
to
have
better intelligence she says that putin
won't stop at ukraine and that he has
designed on the baltics and elsewhere
um
if she's right that means that this
crisis
has to escalate and at some point there
is going to be actual conflict
yes i think what he's trying to do is a
number of things he's trying to do he's
basically trying to rewrite
the sort of european security structures
that we've had since the cold war which
he believes have been shameful for
russia a reverse for russia he's trying
to reintegrate ukraine into russia
because that he believes is something he
wrote a long essay on that recently and
it's something he believes in
he's trying to weaken america and divide
the west and he's trying of course to
bolster uh russian uh control through
force in the near abroad all those are
recognized objectives of russian policy
and what he's trying to do actually is
exploit a moment of what he sees to be
weakness in the west and distraction in
the west in america and in europe to
achieve those goals so there is a risk
that he will act in ukraine and of
course we must be aware that he may have
broader uh objectives that's why
deterring him from this action would
have been uh ideal and if we can't deter
him we are going to need a very strong
united powerful and effective response
to try and limit any further action
if you were in the foreign office now
how important would you regard what k
bailey hutchinson has just
been saying about the need to reduce
european dependence on russian energy
supplies uh what she seemed to be saying
is that the americans ought to be
ramping up their provision of energy to
europe and building facilities so that
you europe can be if you like um
stronger
in facing down putin
well i mean there's a whole series of
lessons that we need to draw uh one is
of course about europe's dependence for
its security on the united states that's
a long running discussion another is
this very important issue about energy
dependency and of course we should be
seeking to address that but let's not
fool ourselves it's not something that
could be solved overnight there is a
whole sort of infrastructure of energy
supply to europe from uh russia
and from the east which you can't just
switch off
easily because you can't necessarily
replace those resources easily there is
of course a lot going on now at looking
at alternative supplies of liquid gas
for example but you have to have the
infrastructure to be able to do that so
yes definitely we should look at it but
it's a serious challenge
simon fraser thank you so much for your
time this morning
thank you
understandably we focused on events to
the east this morning but that doesn't
mean that it's all quiet on the home
front
with may's northern ireland assembly
elections looming current polling
suggests that shin fein could become the
largest party
that would mean that its vice president
michelle o'neill could become first
minister
sky's david blevins has been talking to
her about her vision for northern
ireland
michelle o'neill
you would never accept a trade border
between northern ireland and the
republic so why should unionists accept
one in the irish sea between northern
ireland and the rest of the uk
well dude i don't want to see any
borders we've said from day one that
brexit wasn't compatible with our peace
agreement with our good friday agreement
i've never wanted to see the
interruptions that we're now
experiencing today i think many of us
here warned against the dangers of
brexit and what it actually would mean
for us in reality and we're facing those
challenges today but we sought along
with the majority of other political
parties sought to find mitigation
against the worst impact of brexit that
comes in the form of the protocol so it
protects our peace agreement it protects
the good for the agreement it prevents a
hard border on the island of ireland and
it ensures the continuity of trade
across this island which is obviously
flourishing as a direct result of the
protocol even if we accept that it's
there as a result of brexit you say it
protects the peace process but it has
recently led to the resignation of the
first minister so if it is destabilizing
politics here
isn't a time for you to urge the eu to
find something that wins cross-community
support
well it was never across community
support for brexit the majority of
people here the majority of political
parties on across community bases voted
to reject brexit yet in all it's forced
it upon us this tory government boris
johnson has shown at every turn that
they do not care less for the people who
live here it is in fact the british
government that negotiated the protocol
it is in fact then the signed up to an
international treaty which they have
been putting in jeopardy ever since the
the ink was barely dry on the agreement
itself so we are not in an ideal
situation however the protocol does give
us the best protection and does afford
us a lot of opportunity what can you say
to reassure unionists that the protocol
is the best solution
can you reassure them that it is in your
view just a trade border and that you
respect the position of northern ireland
constitutionally as part of the united
kingdom i signed up to the good friday
agreement so it'll be the people here
alone that will decide if there's
constitutional change there'll never be
anything forested upon people i think
unfortunately for the unionist people
for that wider civic society the
unionist leaders have actually completed
the issue of the protocol and brexit a
mess which they single-handedly
delivered alongside their friends in the
tories and but they have completed that
issue of identity with the issue of
trade which comes about as direct result
of brexit so there are two distinctly
different things there's going to be an
election the polls suggest michelle
o'neill
may be northern ireland's next first
minister
given that the ira campaign
is still in people's memories here it's
not that long ago is northern ireland
ready for a sinn fein first minister
i think it's even crazy that you're even
asking me that question because i think
it'll be the people that will decide who
will there who they will elect who they
will they will decide who will be the
largest party like i come from a
background or a republican you know i'm
a proud republican i'm somebody who i
believe can govern for all people not
just those republican tradition but
those from other traditions so to sit
here in 2022 for anybody to question a
nationalist ability to be first minister
to hold a position in the legal
profession you know to hold the position
of justice ministry is just absolutely
madness those days are gone but but it's
not just any nationalist politician it
is for many people a party that is
still considered to be the political
wing of the ira no matter how long we
are past ceasefires and good friday
agreement so what do you say to victims
of ira violence for example who would
still have a difficulty with the shin
fian first minister
i think that we're a society that comes
from conflict we've had a very difficult
past we have to recognize that we've had
a very difficult past we also have to
recognize that we've all had a very
different experience of the past my
lived experience would be very different
perhaps to someone else of my uh my
generation some of my peers but we have
to recognize that we also have to deal
with the past so this british government
that are intent on trying to cover over
what they did here isn't a good
situation because how do we build for a
better future if we don't properly deal
with the past you talk about the british
trying to cover up the past you're
obviously talking about the proposed
amnesty and historical prosecution of
british army veterans
what's the difference though between
those veterans and and former
paramilitaries be they republican or
loyalist who walked free after the good
friday agreement or who were granted in
the case of many in the ira pardons
well firstly again i mean i do not
support in any shape or form an honesty
of any form for anybody so let me be
very clear about that i am 45 years of
age i'm somebody who has been about the
peace process from this inception i'm
someone who believes in the good freddie
agreement i'm somebody who believes in
dealing with the past so that we all can
move forward together the british
government have tried to block every
step forward in dealing with the past
because for those to say draw a line
under it forget that it happened that
doesn't work the impact of conflict is
intergenerational so today's generation
are still fighting the battles of the
past i don't want myself that for my
children i don't want it for my
grandchildren i don't want it for
anybody else's children if unionists
attempt to block uh shin fan first
minister by refusing to nominate a
deputy is it time to consider voluntary
coalition so that one of the smaller
parties could nominate a deputy first
minister
well firstly let me say this the days of
democracy and the terms of unionism
alone are gone and they're never going
to return so it'll be the people alone
in this election that will decide who
they wish to govern for them and when it
comes to whether or not there should be
a different form of government you have
to remember that we are society coming
out of conflict you have to remember
that we have special and unique
circumstances here so we can't be
looking towards different systems right
now the good for the agreement was an
agreement that a lot of people put a lot
of hard work into nationalism unionist
republican and loyalist a lot of sweat
went in to bring about a peace agreement
that's something that i hold very dearly
and something that i will protect at all
turns so i believe in the system of
governance as a necessary piece of
governance because of where we've come
from
there's a lot of speculation that you
will be first minister of northern
ireland and that your party leader mary
lou mcdonald will be the next taoiseach
the next irish prime minister
if that scenario arises
do you think that immediately opens the
door to your referendum on irish unity
well i certainly think that we're closer
than we ever have been previously and i
think now's the time to plan and that's
why we're saying to the irish government
now is the time for them to make the
preparation let's not fall into the
traps that have been fallen into in
terms of brexit make the preparation
let's start to have a healthy
conversation about the things that
matter every day to people what does the
health service look like in a united
ireland what does education look like in
united ireland so i think that this is a
hopeful conversation because our society
here has lived apart for far too long
because if the last couple of years of
brexit has told us anything is that the
tories will never prioritize the
interests of people here whether you be
unionist nationalist or other earlier
this week people were surprised to hear
your party leader send platinum jubilee
greetings to the queen we've come a long
way from the days when jerry adams was
describing her as mrs windsor
was that just electioneering a reaching
out to the unionist community or the
moderate middle ground community or do
you genuinely respect queen elizabeth of
course i mean i think we have to i mean
we live in a society that's been so
divided and i respect the views of those
of unions that entity those with the
british identity and those people that
look towards the monarchy it's not my
thing but that's okay i can be
respectful enough to understand that for
those for other people in my society who
my community that is important to them
so that's why we sent our best wishes
and you know i do so again today on your
program
michelle o'neill thanks very much thank
you
that's it from us for this week for the
main program
brexit northern ireland covid
warren europe who is it that said that
there's no drama and tension in modern
politics well to be honest i'll be glad
if i can be back here next week
reporting to you that in ukraine there's
nothing much to see
after the break i'll be talking to sam
coates about our big interviews see you
again next week
[Music]
you